first tonight the oso Pious journalist
and the mob and the media and of course
they're close friends they are the
Willing allies and press secretaries for
the Democratic party they are living in
an alternate reality let's give you
exhibit a Hillary Clinton we all know
James Comey admitted it she mishandled
troves of top secret classified material
she attempted to cover it up uh that's
the 30 000 emails they had she destroyed
33 000 other emails that were subpoenaed
uh during an ongoing investigation
Hillary a Democrat she was never rated
she was never charged with a crime and
now of course lacking any and all
self-awareness which is typical of all
things Bill Clinton and Hillary Clinton
my little pumpkin
um is calling the allegations against
Trump beyond anything she has ever
thought possible in this country
uh you sure about this Hillary take a
look their efforts to defend this man
are truly beyond anything that I ever
thought possible in our country I mean
it is so
profoundly disturbing how this could
have been the break this could have been
the opportunity to say you know
uh thank you so much for everything
you've done for us we really appreciate
it you know but this is kind of uh
serious and so we're not going to you
know continue to defend you but no
they're all in again that's what the
psychology of this is so hard for me to
fully grasp psychology of her is hard to
grasp um uh remember we they believe
that our foreign toughest adversaries
saw in real time what was on her servers
they know people that did not have
classification status or looking at a
top secret classified materials Hillary
is delusional but luckily she's never
going to be president uh she should have
been locked up if this is the standard
for Donald Trump on steroids on ABC a
former top aide to Bill Clinton Georgie
Stephanopoulos who's pretending to be a
journalist he's not he's a talk show
host he's a partisan hack and he acts
like a journalist on ABC he's not one
and he doesn't seem to understand why
why Hillary Clinton is relevant to the
ongoing case against Donald Trump well
he over the weekend Senator Lindsey
Graham schooled him and helped educate
ABC's top journalists take a look at
this Donald Trump said repeatedly
repeatedly that he did nothing wrong do
you believe that
well here's what I believe we live in an
America where if you're the Democratic
candidate for president Hillary Clinton
Secretary of State you can set up a
private server in your basement to
conduct government business and when an
investigation has had about your
activity no let me finish
but you didn't answer the question that
was ridiculous well yeah I I'm trying to
answer the question from a republican
point of view that may not be acceptable
on this show yes I don't like what
president Trump did in certain aspects I
don't like that Joe Biden had classified
information on the garage I don't like
that Mike Pence carelessly took
classified information I don't like any
of that but what I don't like is a
system in America where the Secretary of
uh state who's a Democratic candidate
for president
has people take a hammer
to social media devices and break them
apart apply Beach bleach bit to a hard
drive to erase emails allow classified
information to get on a felon's computer
Anthony Weiner you haven't even
mentioned that most Republicans believe
we live in a country where Hillary
Clinton did very similar things and
nothing happened to her president Trump
will have his day in court but Espionage
charges are absolutely ridiculous wow
big moment Lindsey Graham will be here
tonight
the new favorite word of the liberal
media mob and the Democrat whoa It's
called what about ISM or what about
Hillary what about Joe Biden well what
about them do we have equal application
of our laws and equal justice under the
law because it's the very core of what
we believe to be a constitutional
two-tiered system of justice but now we
live in an America with as one standard
for Democrats another for Donald Trump
another for conservatives it is a
blatant government abuse of power the
FBI's politicized the doj's weaponized
and the media mob they only care uh to
support the Democrats regardless of what
the facts say or the double standard
involved you want to speak truth to
power that disappears on all things fake
news CNN and msdnc in the New York Times
And The Washington Post and ABC NBC CBS
especially when the feds are protecting
Democrats and targeting Republicans
America's self-proclaimed journalists
they are gutless they are part of sins
they're not journalists they pretend to
own the truth but refuse to hear any
perspective that just doesn't validate
their own left-wing fantasies take a
look and that's the picture over your
brilliant words we don't need to see
that anymore we know where he is this
case isn't going to be settled legally
in a cafe it's going to be settled in
the court basically the facts and law
the folks in the control room I don't
need to see any more of that this he's
trying to turn this and he's trying to
turn it into a spectacle into a campaign
ad that's enough of that we do not
intend to carry these remarks live
um as we have said before in these
circumstances
there is a cost to us as a news
organization to knowingly broadcast
untrue things I mean all the lies she
all the lies that she told about Russia
and collusion uh talking about truth
pretty laughable after all the NBC News
host is a devout tinfoil hack conspiracy
theorist in her own way card carrying
member of the Russia collusion cult in
fact for several years she and many of
her media mob friends were breathlessly
pushing nothing but lie after lie after
lie day after day week after week month
after month for three long years a
complete hoax read the Durham report
driven by nothing but rage partisanship
stupidity they lied to their viewers
every single night here's a small
reminder
he's afraid of the president of Russia
why um well I think one can speculate as
to why that the Russians may have
something on him personally that they
could always roll out and make his life
more difficult this past weekend is
illustrative of uh what a great case
officer Vladimir Putin is he knows how
to handle an asset and that's what he's
doing with the president no major thing
from the dossier has been conclusively
disproven you know I think we're going
to actually have to stop calling it the
infamous dossier increasingly it's the
accurate dossier increasingly it's the
damning dossier not one word has been
disproven in fact a lot of it turned out
to be right on the money it hasn't been
discredited in fact it's been the
opposite it's been corroborated really
yes really oh okay you're asking your
Intel Community your Intel Community has
corroborated all of the details in there
have to spend the years obsessing over
Russia hoax that never happened and
according to Durham that investigation
Crossfire hurricane never should have
been open and other anti-trump endeavors
can you guess how much time that these
very same people devoted to the foreign
bribery allegations against President
Biden and his son Hunter on June 8th
when both the Trump indictment and Biden
bribery story broke guess what ABC CBS
NBC they devoted a whopping 291 minutes
to Trump's indictment and zero minutes
to the Biden bribery allegations not one
single minute oddly enough the FBI
doesn't seem interested in these
allegations either now think about the
uh credible FBI Source by the way the
FBI deemed the source of this 1023 so
credible the FBI had previously paid
this person hundreds of thousands of
dollars for Intel and now this person is
accusing Biden of accepting a five
million dollar foreign bribe as vice
president in exchange for a policy
decision I guess his uh credentials go
out the window the source claiming that
a barista executive has 17 separate
recording of phone calls 15 with Hunter
two with then Vice President Joe Biden
uh backing up his allegations and the
tapes were made as quote an insurance
policy that would mean your president's
compromised and yet the FBI seemingly
doing it all all they can do to obstruct
lawmakers like James Comer and Jim
Jordan from investigating these claims
and needless to say yesterday on Capitol
Hill the FBI's deputy director not
exactly forthcoming and he got an earful
from Senator Ted Cruz take a look
the informant alleges that President
Biden
and his family members engaged in a five
million dollar bribery scheme
during his time as vice president
deputy director abadi is it true that
the FBI has a report making those
allegations
I'm not going to comment on that Senator
and why is that
I'm just not going to comment on uh
information we received investigations
you have an obligation to the American
people to be candid about evidence of
corruption by the president of the
United States
this is a an area that I'm not going to
get into with you Senator well I
understand you don't want to and that's
why people are mad at the FBI because
you're stonewalling and covering up
serious allegations of evidence of
corruption from the president
does that Inspire confidence no it does
not that's why more people now do not
trust the FBI according to a new
Rasmussen poll meanwhile the feds are
only getting started with Donald Trump
reports now they want even more charges
out of Washington D.C and maybe New
Jersey and then of course Georgia is it
ever going to stop but as of now even
Hunter he's a free man they had his
laptop from hell since 2019 no charges
and there's a lot of crimes right there
on the on the laptop take a look at it
and are overtly now abusively biased
justice system it is broken beyond
belief if left unchecked it will destroy
the fabric of our country we might as
well shred our Constitution and say bye
bye American Pie because you have you
know all these people these Ivory Tower
Democrats and their media mob don't seem
to care hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis us you will
not get it anywhere else